so in a normal economy we know that
employment we know that employment will
drive overall demand if we have high
employment or low unemployment then
people are going to have more jobs and
they're going to have higher wages and
that'll have higher demand or if the
other way goes around if they lose their
jobs demand is going to go down wages
will start to go down and people aren't
going to have money in their pockets so
that employment drives demand and we can
view demand and I'm making a huge
simplification here demand will drive
production or maybe we could think of it
as supply it'll Drive supply and it will
also Drive it can also be a driver of
price and of course there is a little
bit of a negative feedback loop for both
of these things if the demand is high
and the price goes high that might
produce a little bit of negative
feedback on the demand this type of a
sort of an arrow this line here means
negative feedback up a little negative
sign here and let's say the demand is
high and then the supply goes high well
that might also make that might also
make the demand
well actually the supply going high
would drive the price going down so
maybe I should draw a negative feedback
like here high supply would mean lower
price but that's not what I want to
focus on in that video and we could keep
adding more lines here but this is a
roughly simple take on it but the
general idea is supply and price supply
and price will then drive corporate
profits or just profits in general even
for an individual business owner and
then profits are going to drive are
going to drive employment now let's
imagine a scenario we are in a bad
economy maybe a depression like economy
so in that situation you can start
really at any point in the circle I'll
just start an unemployment so let's say
employment is really low that's going to
make demand really low and if demand is
really low then supply is going to go
down and price is going to go down and
then that's going to make profits go
down and that's going to make employment
even lower and so what we find ourselves
in this kind of recessionary or
depression area environment this would
be called a deflationary spiral the
flash' nari
deflationary spiral and it's a spiral
because the bad economy is driving lower
prices which is in turn driving a bad
economy and to make matters worse if
this continues long enough or if these
price declines are severe enough you
could imagine people saying look I have
this dollar in my pocket
I'm not going to spend this dollar
because one I might lose my job at any
moment or and I know that that dollar is
becoming more powerful that it's I can
buy more every minute that I wait so as
the price goes down so as all of the
scary stuff happens so the employment is
going down profits are going down price
is going down this makes people not
hoard goods and services the way that or
at least hoard goods the way that they
would do in an inflationary spiral but
it makes them hoard money
it makes them hoard money and why it's
ultra scary for central bankers or for
government's is they start to not as
have as much control over the economy
they can't just run the printing press
and try to stimulate the economy in this
situation because if they did people are
so conservative right now you can
imagine maybe the depression is going on
for years and years and years and let's
say that they take some type of a
helicopter and this isn't how you
actually distribute money into the money
supply but it's a it's just to show an
extreme example so they take a
helicopter and they start dumping cash
on people they print cash and they start
dumping it on people so every man woman
and child in the country gets a ten
dollar bill well if people are really
scared and really afraid they're just
going to take the $10 bill and stuff it
into their mattress and it's not going
to change anything that dollar isn't
going to actually enter into the money
supply the velocity on it will be zero